and I have a right to ask simple fair
questions how do you know that how can I
trust that how and if and if you don't
give me those answers then I just don't
believe you you don't have to believe me
you don't have to believe Ronda santis
you don't have to believe Kim Reynolds
or anything else you have to make a
decision for yourself I think that is
the important thing here you have to
take the information what I try to do is
just give you guys some information I
tell you what I think you have to take
some of that information and then figure
out what you think right you don't want
to be you can turn on many other shows
where guys are just going to yell over
the top and try to convince you of every
other thing that's not the way to do it
I think maybe it's why this thing's
working over here and it's also why
people are paying attention to Tucker
Carlson so one more from that interview
the only thing that enrages me is when
you hear people say you know you must
believe me I have no obligation to
believe anybody you have an obligation
if you want me to believe you to prove
what you're saying right and I have a
right to ask simple fair questions how
do you know that how can I trust that
how and if and if you don't give me
those answers then I just don't believe
you and I don't have to believe you and
if your recourse is you're a bad person
for not believing me you that's my
response
you not end the show by saying that but
I will end the show by saying think for
yourself think for yourself make some of
these decisions for yourself think about
like how do we get out of this like is
the truth that we can make America great
again right now or is the truth that we
better freaking save America First make
America with great again was nice now I
think we're at the stage of like we got
to save this freaking thing or we are
going to you know just Veer off that
cliff into hell I would prefer not to do
that